a woman freaked out on an American
Airlines flight over the weekend and
since we now live in a culture that
encourages people to film people in
distress rather than to help them the
poor lady has gone viral
I'm telling you I'm getting the off
and there's a reason why I'm getting the
off of everyone can either Believe
it or they cannot believe it I don't
give two but I am telling you right ow
that mother
that back there is not real
and you can sit on this plane and you
can die with them or not I'm not going
to ah
so what happened was the woman having a
psychotic break
did she have a few too many drinks at
the airport bar
was her seat mate not real
I don't know it seems unlikely but maybe
Matt's right and she saw an alien or
maybe since Matt is not right maybe she
saw a demon I don't know I don't know
I have very little interest in observing
a woman's apparent meltdown on an
airplane
but I have a great interest in observing
culture and I can't help but notice in
this case how different the reaction is
from the last big viral moment that our
whole culture embraced a couple of
months ago
a vagrant violent criminal with a rap
sheet a mile long a man who had recently
beaten up elderly men and women walked
onto a New York City subway train and
threatened to kill people and our
culture makers our media our political
establishment
they treated that man as the most
innocent downtrodden sympathetic
breakdancer ever to moonwalk onto the F
train
an oppressed black man struck down by
the scourge of white supremacy that
ubiquitous deadly scourge
and then this past weekend a white woman
had an emotional outburst and walked off
an airplane without threatening anyone
and she is now a universal object of
mockery and derision a dumb stupid Karen
who should probably be arrested and put
on some meds
what matters about the airline freakout
video is not whether that lady thought
her seat mate was a real person or not
more significant about the video is
whether the viewers
think the lady freaking out is a real
person herself I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by my very good friends
at good ranchers get great meat at a
secure price and 30 bucks off your order
with my code Knolls I had good ranchers
last night had a rib eye and it was the
bomb.com head on over to
goodranchers.com use my code Knowles
today uh speaking of viral moments
there's another one that's gone viral
now because a mainstream Network news
Outlet is celebrating a video of two men
taking a baby and claiming it is theirs
I will get into that a little bit later
first though I don't want to move off
the lady on the airplane just yet
because there was a major update this
morning when I saw that video I thought
like maybe she had a few too many at the
airport
tap into the best of us but what did she
see she probably saw something she she's
clearly afraid of something and because
I recognize that there is spiritual
warfare in the world I thought I don't
know maybe I don't know maybe she saw
something that at least signified or
symbolized something that might be real
and genuinely scary and then my
associate producer young Jacob today was
it Mr Davies one of the two of them
points out that there's a follow-up
video by a guy who says he's the one who
freaked the woman out and the guy turns
out to be a face tattooed Freemason who
called himself Lucifer all right so the
internet has heard the story of the
woman on the plane with the reptilians
but thanks to her delaying the flight I
just got home so now it's my opportunity
to tell my side of the story as the guy
in the hoodie
so we're attempting to fly out of Dallas
Fort Worth and then basically this woman
she sits next to me and she's clearly
been drinking I'm minding my own
business and sure enough she sees my
hoodie that has a Freemason logo on it
put a post right there I'm just minding
my own business this you know
Ben Shapiro of every observation he's
ever made in his life his best one is
the observation about face tattoo
syndrome which is someone someone
tattoos their whole face they make a
huge spectacle of themselves in a way
that is really spooky and grotesque and
then they just wait for you to notice it
and then they get angry when you notice
it see what are you looking at
what are you looking at oh I don't know
the the attention you demanded that's
what I'm offering you because you've
tattooed your face in a way that is
menacing and spooky and you've got all
these occult symbols all over you and
then you get angry at me for noticing
the thing that you're begging me to
notice keep going
and on top of that she's noticed my ring
so she started to ask questions nothing
dramatic just asked me do I know what
these symbols mean why am I wearing it
what's the purpose yada yada and long
story short I basically just say hey I'm
a Freemason I even briefly explained how
I educate about Freemasonry here on Tick
Tock next thing I know she basically
starts to grill me about low-level
Freemason and that it's all Satanism and
that it's ruled by reptilians and blah
blah blah so I simply put my hood up and
I started to ignore her and basically
just mind my own business she starts
getting louder and louder and then
basically she's like you know that they
worship Lucifer at the top right so I I
looked at her dead in her eyes and I
said I am Lucifer I've heard one
individual laugh behind me so I figured
somebody got a kick out of it at least
she starts running up and down the
aisles freaking out saying I'm a
reptilian and then all this other stuff
she's gonna get off the plane yada yada
it doesn't show all the footage it just
says that she's trying to get off the
plane because of you know I'm not going
to say it here on Tick Tock I don't want
to get banned but then also talking
about how like I'm secretly also trying
to take over the world so I look back at
the guy that was basically chuckling
before and I winked at him so I
basically whispered something under my
breath saying that Freemasons don't care
to rule the world we ruled the universe
and I look back at the guy that was
laughing before and just kind of winked
at him because he started laughing again
well I didn't think that she could hear
me but evidently she did and it is a big
joke further and then they'd like and so
on so forth so immoral of the story
don't believe everything you hear on the
internet
and Freemasons don't care to rule the
world when we rule the universe
so
this was a Twist that not a lot of
people expected the woman especially if
if we're assuming she had a few drinks
at the airport bar
pretty much totally Vindicated right he
put yourself in her shoes
and you're sitting there next to a face
tatted up guy who's got a cult symbolism
all over his body who says that he's
Lucifer and controls the Universe I
I think she's pretty Vindicated and
Justified now you might say well he's
just joking
he's just being ironic and
I guess my objection to that point is
I think irony ends once you tattoo your
face I think that's pretty much the end
of irony I've observed on this show
before that if you behave in an ironic
way for your whole life it's no longer
ironic it becomes Earnest because
there's no way to distinguish between
irony and sincerity I think the moment
that tattoo gun hits your face that's
when the irony sees this I think you're
pretty committed to the bid at that
point
and esotericists and hermetic sort of
Cults that worship illumination and all
that sort of thing I don't know if
you're if you're calling if you're
saying that you control the universe and
you got the tats and the symbols I don't
you know
I'm not saying I would have stormed off
the plane I probably just would have
said a couple of prayers
you know maybe talk to the guy figured
out what he actually believes beyond all
these kinds of slogans but maybe if I'd
had one or two too many Rose like that
lady perhaps did
I might have just walked off the plane
too okay that's real talk when you want
real talk
you also probably want some pure talk
and when you want Pure Talk you got to
go check out my friends over at
pure talk right now go to puretalk.com
Knowles you know a company is looking
out for you when they actually upgrade
your service and don't charge you for it
this is great news for new and current
Pure Talk customers pure talk just added
data to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but you have not made the
switch take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 50 percent more 5G
data plus their new mobile hotspot this
is why I love Pure Talk they're veteran
owned and the only hire the very best
customer service team located right here
in the great us of a most families are
saving almost a thousand dollars a year
while enjoying the most Dependable 5G
Network in America remember you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you when you go to
puretalk.com Knowles you'll save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they value EU pure
Wireless for Americans by Americans
speaking of
the culture
speaking of women who seem incoherent
and less justifiably so in this case
Kamala Harris our vice president
she has
thoughts on our culture well I think
culture is it it is a reflection of our
moment and our time right and and and
present culture is the way we express
how we're feeling about the moment
and
and we should always find times to
express how we feel about the moment
that is a reflection of Joy because
every you know
it comes in the morning
we have to find ways to also Express the
way we feel about the moment in terms of
just having language and and a
connection to how people are
experiencing life and I think about it
in that way too
culture is the Norms rituals and
behaviors of a given people
that's the answer she was looking for it
was it's just it's ninth grade English
class
when you haven't read the book
and you you are in the you're in the
honors class but you maybe you don't
belong in the honors class and you
haven't done the work anyone you said
well
you know culture where do I begin it's
you know culture is an expression of our
moment and that's and culture is
how we react to our the expression of
the moment and it's the moment and it's
joy in the morning and uh well I think
we pretty much
[Music]
yeah but do you have an answer to what
that is
no there's something really profound in
kamala's just circular and meaningless
description of culture here which is
that our culture presently is circular
and meaningless so
a keen insight about culture was given
to us by the sociologist Renee Gerard
who who pointed out that culture is
mimetic that we
human beings develop our personalities
our behaviors our language our thoughts
our desires even by imitating what we
see from other people and so a culture
that values honor is going to uh you
know let's say a monarchy traditionally
that's a culture that places a high
value on honor that culture is going to
increase in honor and in the desire for
Honor because we're all going to be
imitating each other republics
traditionally are understood as cultures
that value virtue and so they're gonna
be they're going to look different than
monarchies they're going to look
different than aristocracies and that's
going to spread too because we're going
to imitate one another the reason that
you want the nice Rolex watch is not
because you know anything about horology
or time keeping or swiss arts and crafts
it's because people that you admire and
people who you would like to be more
like want the Rolex watch that's that's
how that's how we come to this even
desire these sorts of
luxury goods that's and that would be
one of the artifacts that defines a
culture right and so all of that to say
our present culture
doesn't really value much of anything at
all
we don't value honor we don't believe in
honor anymore we don't value virtue we
don't believe in virtue anymore we don't
we do value stuff to some degree though
actually
decreasingly so if you see surveys about
Millennials and Zoomers especially we
don't really value cars anymore we don't
really value having a house anymore we
don't really value High fashion anymore
we don't even value stuff we value
nothing other than the satisfaction of
our most
animalistic desires and so human culture
starts to go away anything resembling
High culture disappears we don't have
beautiful architecture we don't have
beautiful art we don't have beautiful
music we don't have beautiful Customs or
rituals anymore it's all just kind of
base level satisfy your sexual appetite
satisfy your physical appetites not even
with
High Cuisine with kind of cheap nothing
Cuisine where we're just eating slop
basically from fast food places or from
impossible burgers or from what a soil
and milkshakes or whatever else you're
going to have so
that that's an anti-culture perfectly
expressed by Kamala Harris in this
circular rambling because we don't have
any sense of what we value anymore
because we don't have any grounding in
reality anymore and and as our society
moves further away from grounded
tangible reality into the metaverse into
virtual digital social media into the
abstraction from the self of of the self
from the body saying that our true
selves have nothing to do with our
bodies anymore as that happens the
culture is going to collapse even
further and and it's become almost
cliche now to observe that we today
could not build medieval Cathedrals we
couldn't do it we don't even know how
they were built
Notre Dame in Paris
the roof burns down we don't know how to
fix it we've got we're just gonna have
to replace it with something uglier we
can't do it anymore that culture has
been lost
the apotheosis of that culture is the
incoherent rambling that you're getting
from now the vice president of the
United States speaking of our culture
and the the fleeting aspects that could
even Define our anti-culture as it
exists
of the Blessed celebrity
gretathenberg was just arrested in
Sweden
she was arrested for protesting fossil
fuels or something and they arrested her
she's 20 years old now by the way they
keep pretending she's like 12 but you
know she's an adult now and she was
arrested and could be charged with a
crime and could be sentenced to six
months in prison but she won't be even
the media Outlets who are reporting on
this who were liberal and very
sympathetic to creda or say she'll
probably just get off with a fine and
some of her big liberal backers will pay
off that fine and it won't matter at all
and she'll just go back to getting
arrested next time
that's because this protest which
presents itself as being opposed to the
system opposed to the established Powers
it is actually part of the system
protesting is part of the liberal ruling
order that's why the liberal ruling
class encouraged the BLM riots a few
years ago the riots were not in
opposition to any system they were part
of the system and protests have been
part of the system for at least 500
years I guess about 500 years of
modernity and you see that especially
kick up in something like the French
Revolution which puts modernity into
overdrive and and tears down the order
you see this in the Bolshevik Revolution
you see this uh increasingly the the
protests that tear down the edifices of
the of the old regime of the old culture
of Christendom of the West they tear
that down but they tear it down not in
spite of the liberal ruling class that
currently runs our civilization but with
the encouragement of that ruling class
because that ruling class is a liberal
ruling class that wants to tear down all
the old stuff that wants to tear down
tradition that wants to tear down the
church that wants to tear down the
family that wants to tear down the high
Earth that wants to tear down all the
stuff that makes us
us as a society this is also why it's
mostly futile for conservatives to
engage in the same kinds of protests and
activism that the left has been engaging
in for centuries we occasionally try to
do it and it's usually half-hearted
because it's just not really in the
conservative sensibility to take to the
streets and scream and yell in protests
like we're great at unburg or something
like that but also it's not going to
work because the system will clamp down
on us the system won't clamp down on
them BLM can go burn down the country
for eight months system's going to at
the most give them a little slap on the
wrist
can go make a nuisance of herself
everywhere the system will not punish
her ever but a Midwestern granny shows
up to the capital rotunda and takes a
selfie you know next to Nancy Pelosi's
lectern or something she's going into
solitary confinement
so the the system reacts differently
because there the system is built for
Liberal protests that furthers the goals
of the regime conservative protest which
is mostly incoherent you know the great
strides that conservatives and
proto-conservatives have ever made have
not been won through activism in the
streets
screaming and yelling like we're the
weather underground or something that
doesn't that that's not how we roll the
greatest strides that the the the the
right the conservatives the people who
are on our side of the culture have ever
made are are the martyrs dancing as the
lions eat them in in the early church
because the blood of the martyrs was the
seed of the church that's a that's a
hard lesson to learn and none of us
really is eager for that probably but
but that's that's more in our
sensibility uh than you know going out
and yelling and screaming uh to to no
good end because we'll we'll just be
rounded up and arrested and meanwhile
Greta will go down and hold another
another big show
we're not going to beat the system by
being part of the system it's one of the
big
battles right now on the American right
is we're recognizing that we have
unknowingly imbibed and accepted so many
of the libs premises
this is why can conservatives at least
for the last 50 60 years have basically
just been liberals driving the speed
limit
as I think Michael malice has
popularized that phrase other people
have said it too and that's true you
don't you don't want to just be liberals
driving the speed limit you want to
offer a choice rather than
an echo moving on from greater getting
into famous children there's a big
update on coke gate
you know you remember how they found a
little bit of that old first son
favorite booger sugar in the West Wing
you know what I'm talking about you know
I'm you know what I'm saying I'm talking
about that old Peruvian nose candy you
know what I'm talking about I mean that
Yale College baking powder you know
cocaine
they found some in the White House and
the Biden Administration is doing its
damnedest to to bury it under the rug
buried under the carpet bury it up in
the first Sun's nose but the excuses are
pretty weak which we'll get to in a
second first though when you want to
consume things that are good for you
you're probably going to grill them up
on the grill this summer and when you do
that you're going to need to check out
Grill Blazer right now go to
grillblazer.com Knowles thanks to our
friends at Grill Blazer instant barbecue
Perfection is at the touch of your
fingertips Grill Blazers Grill guns are
designed to do everything from expertly
searing your Meats to lighting charcoal
grills wood stoves outdoor fireplaces
and just about anything you can think of
where you would need high power fire to
solve your problem I may or may not have
sparked up a stogie with a grill Blazer
gun you may have seen that grow Blazers
offers two types of Grill guns the grill
gun basic is a high power propane torch
designed to Light charcoal and wood
grills and smokers burns up to 3 600
Degrees it's 30 30 inch flame is pretty
much all you need a big bad torch to do
and then there's the SUV gun shorter
Barrel perfect for professional Culinary
Kitchen uses from gently caramelizing
brulee or other sugars and fruits to
rapidly searing steaks outside on the
grill warning the grill gun will result
in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors right now go get the grill gun
from Grill Blazers go to grillblazer.com
Knowles use promo code nulls for 15 off
your order grillblazer.com
promo code Knolls for 15 off your order
the greatest interview show on the
internet many people are talking about
it yes or no is back with an all new
episode discussing the number one movie
in America sound of freezes and the
sound of freezing
sound of Freedom with the movie star Jim
Caviezel and operation Underground
Railroad founder Tim Ballard they joined
me for tough questions and stiff drinks
you do not want to miss this episode
it's just the coincidence that many
Elites in Hollywood and big Tech are
also some of the harshest critics of the
sound of Freedom movie does Michael
think it's a coincidence just thinking
about it for a second
don't give me the answer
it's cheating it's cheating
here's some good news folks yes or no
the game
is now back in stock you can go to
dailyword.com shop to get the game today
the games go very fast they are selling
extremely quickly as I've said every
time we've ordered some and then they've
sold out
same thing is going to happen here yes
or no's hands down the best way to add a
little spice to your parties challenge
your friends and Family's knowledge
delve into the most thought-provoking
topics of our time go to dailyword.com
shop and order the yes or no game today
before it sells out
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Master Kenobi who says Michael your
talking points are great and all but
your style never disappoints thank you
very much I appreciate that glad you
think I got that drip and that Riz it is
uh Tom Ford Friday over here at the
daily wire I have gotten our wardrobe
Department to buy me very expensive
Italian kind of clothing
which is which is great thank goodness
I'm married could you imagine if if I
got this kind of a wardrobe this kind of
a drip when I was single it would have
been over man would have been would not
have been conducive to Virtue not a not
a not a chance now speaking of things
that are not conducive to Virtue the
first son Hunter Biden visited the White
House
and then
a little bit of that Colombian cumin was
found you know what I mean a little bag
of that old old powder it's found in the
White House and supposedly we have no
idea where it came from initially we
were told it was always in the White
House residence so then you think it was
the Biden family then we were told no
actually it was in a really highly
trafficked area of the White House so it
could have been anybody it could have
been some tourist walking in someone
just getting a quick view of the White
House then we were told no it was in a
much more secure area of the White House
you pretty much would have had to be a
member of the Biden family or a cabinet
secretary to get into this part of the
White House without being fully searched
so the White House Deputy press
secretary Andrew Bates was asked about
cocaine gate
here's his non-answer
one more you know president uh former
president Trump has made some pretty
wild posts recently on social media one
of them was that uh the cocaine found
the White House was it belonged to
either the president or his son are you
willing to say that that's not the case
that they don't belong to them
I I don't have uh a response to that
because we have to be careful about the
Hatch Act uh what I will say is that I
have noticed there does seem to be some
increasing frustration coming from that
corner in general
and I think it is probably rooted in the
contrast between their substantive
policy records I can't uh the Hatch Act
the Hatch Act is the weakest sauce
answer you can ever give as a press
secretary to a question that you don't
want to answer the Hatch Act is totally
fake for those who don't know the Hatch
Act says that if you are working in a
government role you can't engage in
political campaign activities and
everybody violates this thing all the
time and it's pretty much never enforced
Karine Jean-Pierre the White House Press
Secretary the boss here of of this guy
she will frequently use the Hatch Act as
an excuse not to give answers to tough
questions about Joe Biden but she was
found herself to have violated the Hatch
Act and on at least one occasion I
suspect she's done it on many more
occasions because if you're working in
politics in any role then you're working
in politics and it's very muddy and it's
a it's a stupid answer
even if the Hatch Act were legit and
were ever seriously enforced
how would it be a violation of the Hatch
Act to comment on the illicit drug on
the narcotic that was found in The West
Wing
in what way could that possibly violate
the hatchback it's just an answer they
don't want to give because
most people have a strong suspicion on
where it came from
and uh
they know that the Biden family will
never be held to account for anything if
you can take tens of millions of dollars
in bribes from hostile foreign powers by
selling American influence
and not face really any any consequences
for that you're not going to face
consequences for a dime bag of coke it's
just not going to happen Okay speaking
of
things that should be illegal and laws
that should be enforced
CBS News just celebrated a moment on
social media CBS News tweeted out
this is the moment
[Music]
the whole liberal system that has
encouraged this not good stuff now when
you want to feel a little bit better
about all the things that are going on
in this world if you want to get back to
basics and treat your body as you should
treat it
you got to check out good ranchers right
now go to goodranchers.com use promo
code at Knowles if you have not heard
yet the FDA has approved lab-grown
chicken for sale yes meat formed in a
lab will soon be coming to a store near
you if you prefer meat grown in a
pasture instead of a petri dish then you
need good ranchers not only do they sell
real meat from real animals but they
sell the best meat this country has to
offer from Steakhouse quality cuts of
beef to better than organic chicken
everything good ranchers sources is from
local farms in America plus right now
you'll get 30 bucks off with my code
nolts kwles goodranchors.com they've got
genuinely great products and top tier
customer service you can't call the
scientists in the lab to ask about their
fake meat but good ranchers has a team
of people available for you to call and
answer all your questions real meat real
service what are you waiting for enjoy
real meat and real service today with
goodranters goodranchors.com use promo
code Knolls for 30 bucks off any box
promo code Knowles at goodranchors.com
goodranchors.com American meat delivered
this mailbag
is sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select plan enter code
nulls kwles to get 55 zero percent off
your first month
take it away
hey Michael you talk a lot about how the
DeSantis versus Trump race
is about the original versus the
derivative
and I agree that if Rona Sanchez is
going to have a clear path to Victory he
needs to reframe that contest entirely
and the way that he has to do it is to
convince Americans that this is not
between the original and the derivative
but between the ultimate and the
derivative
in which case Ron DeSantis would be the
ultimate conservative president and and
Donald Trump would be a mere stepping
stone towards achieving that ultimate
conservatism
the way he needs to do this
is by being an explicitly Christian
candidate by saying that all of his
policies are going to be viewed through
a Christian lens and his driving
governmental philosophy is going to be
that of Christianity
um conservatism at its heart is
Christian so if you would do this I
think that he would make
a big leap forward and I would like to
hear your thoughts on it thanks
I basically agree with that and that
question may have come in before I made
a very similar point yesterday on the
show that's true I think
probably the Consultants around DeSantis
might fear that a Deus volt explicitly
Christian campaign
might
hurt him with the supposed Suburban moms
or you know the Suburban women and the
moderate voters and all these kinds of
people but I I agree with you it's
really his only shot
probably DeSantis is only shot right now
in this race is to run as Ted Cruz
which wouldn't work had Ted Cruz decided
to run in 2024 but because Senator Cruz
has not run in 2024
Cruz ran as the Christian Conservative
candidate now Senator Cruz is more
libertarian probably than Governor
DeSantis which right now that
distinction would benefit DeSantis given
where the conservative movement is at
the moment so he could
he could try to run as the
more traditionalist type of Ted Cruz but
people will poo poo that strategy
because they'll say well Cruz lost to
Trump
yeah he did but we we blur over a lot of
the details in hindsight
had Marco Rubio dropped out before
Florida Ted Cruz probably would have
been the Republican nominee Ted Cruz was
very very close to beating Donald Trump
in the 2016 primary and he ran as a
distinct figure Trump ran as this wild
populist who totally bucks the system
who is not from the elite who kind of
attended one of the fancy schools though
he was a transfer student and he was
never really accepted by them he doesn't
come from old money he doesn't hop
around to all the classic institutions
of the political establishment he is not
invited to nice cocktail party is he
and
Ron DeSantis did go to the fancy schools
he went to Yale and Harvard and Ron
DeSantis did serve in Congress for a
while and Ron DeSantis has been a
governor of estate and so it's not a
knock on him I think he's a very
effective politician but he can't run as
that total Outsider Ronda Santos has
support from a lot of the GOP
establishment
again I still don't think that's a knock
on DeSantis I think they're just
supporting him because he's not Donald
Trump and he's the only guy who could
take Trump out but that's something that
that DeSantis has to deal with and and I
think maybe the way to deal with that is
to just lean in and say look I am going
to be the candidate to the right of
Donald Trump and he's starting to do
that by the way you're seeing this with
a great ad from Casey DeSantis going
after uh some of the the eccentricities
of the left hitting hitting the left for
going after conservatives kids you're
seeing this in the anti-pride month ad
that DeSantis put out and so he's
starting to do that but he he's got to
distinguish himself because if it's a if
it's a battle between Coke and New Coke
New Coke might perform better in the
taste tests that are blind but when you
take the blindfold off people are always
going to go for the OG next one
hey Michael I'm in a little bit of a
pickle here and I'm hoping you can
unpickle me with some words of wisdom
throughout the month of June I posted a
lot of anti-pride things very simple
things like men cannot be women we
shouldn't affirm
and that the Rainbow Coalition will be
the downfall of America my husband has
two siblings who are a part of the
Rainbow Coalition and they of course
became incredibly upset about this and
were screaming at me that I was being
hateful and all sorts of other things
um it got so bad that they called their
parents crying and so now my husband's
parents are upset with me for creating
this contention in their household and
even though they agree with me 100 and
have no issue with what I said they
don't want me to talk about or post
these things for the sake of not
upsetting their two children in the
Bible you know Christ encourages us to
be peacemakers as he is and that
contention is of the devil my question
is where is the line between stating
what is true and what we believe in and
standing firm in the faith and not
creating contention because we know that
those subjects will upset certain people
in our lives am I responsible for the
contention or is it up to the two
children to control their emotions and
be tolerant of opposing ideas thanks so
much Michael it's even further for it's
it's important for the children to be
raised in in accordance with the truth
not just to be tolerant but to be to be
raised in a way that is correct to be
shaped properly and oriented toward the
truth rather than toward falsehood so
it's even further than that and you
ought to State your views
in the proper media and on the proper
platforms I don't think you need to show
up to Thanksgiving dinner wearing a Maga
hat you know dancing around setting off
fireworks for the conservative
Revolution or anything like that but if
it's on your own social media page if
it's if it's in your own book club I
don't know if it's in if it's
a dinner with like-minded people then of
course you bring that up and then when
you go to the family function then maybe
you're a little bit more diplomatic
there's nothing wrong with being
diplomatic you don't want to be a
flatterer you don't want to be a liar
you don't want to say things that aren't
true but you don't all need to be
flamboyant all the time with your views
kind of funny to use the word flamboyant
when we're talking about your opposition
to the pride movement
so I would speak the truth
or at all times but you can be a little
more
bold and a little more subdued depending
on the circumstances but I would never
try to
find a conciliatory Middle Ground
between truth and falsehood that's where
you're going to get into trouble because
if you try to back away from your views
no I don't really mean that no I
actually I kind of look I sort of see
but maybe in the then you're going to
look guilty then you're going to look
like your your views are wrong and so
which they're not if you're asked by
your relatives do you really believe
that
you don't believe in gay marriage you
say no I don't I just don't think that's
what marriage is I think that marriage
essentially has to do with sexual
difference and so no don't mean any ill
will toward anybody but it's just that's
just what it is I can't I can't lie
then you're in a much safer position
because you can't they're not going to
be able to argue with you and you're not
going to seem nervous you're not going
to seem like like what you're doing is
something shameful you're stating your
abuse clearly might even be persuasive
next question
hi Michael this is the shukmeister I
have probably the most important
question to ask regarding the lore of
the Michael Knowles show there seems to
be a reoccurring antagonist and I was
once again reminded of him during your
interview with SD Williams who is Mr
McGillicuddy and why does he want to
steal my future Trad wife away from me
thanks love the show
well Mr McGillicuddy you know he owns
the widget Factory at which your wife
works so that you can get money so that
you can pay another woman to raise your
children
that Mr McGillicuddy is perhaps the
defining man in our Modern Life
predicted by James Burnham with the rise
of the managerial Elite in the
earlier parts of the 20th century
and now really has flourished where we
live in a society that is
undifferentiated by almost anything and
especially sex
and everybody's got to go work and just
produce widgets to tick up GDP and then
consume products rather than focus on
things that don't have a price tag like
family
Mr McGillicuddy is not a communist
a lot of conservatives want to blame all
the problems on Communists and I blamed
Marx and Marx's acolytes for all sorts
of issues I wrote a whole book about it
called speechless controlling words
controlling minds but there are hello
thank you but there are
other
evils in the world besides Marxism there
are other antagonists and and Mr
McGillicuddy is a real Insidious
antagonist
is Mr McGillicuddy though he is liberal
is a capitalist
capitalism is a word that was
popularized by Karl Marx and capitalism
is
is not great
markets are good a flourishing economy
is good material Prosperity can be a
wonderful thing in its proper place
but capitalism is the greatest highest
point of politics
makes conservatives no different than
the Mammon worshipers on the left that
we deride and that we we distinguish
ourselves from
that's who he is next question
hey there Big Mike Smokey Mike Sexy Mike
Dirty Mike Media Matters for America's
favorite quote-unquote failed actor I
wanted to inquire a question for your
answering pleasure I want to get some
information on a topic you are well
versed in cigars not marijuana no if I
wanted information on the red Pitchfork
man's favorite crop I will just asked a
goofy little leftist but I'd digress I
digress
I was hoping you could give me a general
explanation about cigars like what
they're made of what makes two cigars
different general information that's
important to know for somebody trying to
get into this and also as someone who
has dealt with asthma in the past but it
doesn't really affect me now would it
still be possible for me to get into
this activity really appreciate the
response keep up the good work and God
bless oh make sure to tell your folk
sizes hey all right good deal bye now
what a question what an amazing question
I don't really know anything about
asthma so talk to your doctor I guess if
you're not asthmatic now I don't see
what the problem would be I don't really
know the relation between tobacco and
Asthma anyway uh in terms of cigars what
are they made of they're made of tobacco
they're made of tobacco leaves
unlike a cigarette which is made of
chopped up Cheap Tobacco and chemicals
and paper
cigar is all tobacco it's long filler
tobacco it comes from different
countries Cuba most famously but then
because of the Cuban embargo and because
the Communists stole the crops from the
the and the plantations from the cigar
makers a lot of the great cigar makers
left they went to places like the
Dominican Republic Nicaragua Honduras
increasingly Ecuador of some tobacco is
grown in Mexico some of the best tobacco
is grown in Connecticut
shade tobacco and darker broadleaf
tobacco which is very toothy kind of
nice oily juicy tobacco though a lot of
that tobacco now there's a shortage of
it because the the Connecticut Farms
have sold to other places so a lot of
that is actually grown in Ecuador now
um uh the the cigars taste different
because you blend different kinds of
tobacco together
I've considered
making cigar is a bigger part of the
show
because it's such a great pleasure it's
given me such a great pleasure over the
course of my life
i've smoked cigars for the majority of
my life at this point I tried to in
moderation understanding the risks
Trying to minimize them uh and I think
it's it really has helped me it helps me
to relax helps me to think about things
wonderful conversations so we'll try to
do a little bit more with cigars moving
moving forward but today's fake headline
Friday I want to get to some more
questions from the member block I want
to read my iPad where is it where is it
producer Jacob the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code knowleskin WWE
has a checkout for two months free on
all annual plans
[Music]